welcome to irrational science
why are we rational well because most
everybody out there
is not that's why we do rational science
here rational physics
today we have a couple ladies that we're
going to be talking about who do
a lot of irrational physics we're going
to discuss
why they do irrationality only in other
words they do
religion that's what they do here are
these two ladies we're going to present
them fine ladies here
uh one is becky smithers then the other
one is diana calmer
and the first one who went on the left
she is from oxford she's an
astro math magician she does all kinds
of magic
uh in the astro world in the cosmic
world
she's a junior research fellow uh at a
church
christ church oxford anglican church
uh i guess uh they turned those into
laboratories now
you can work in there uh to do some
so-called uh astronomy and she's a
mathematics communicator on youtube
and her moniker is uh dr becky yeah
she's got a
in order to do to be a junior research
fellow you must have
a phd or apparently
it's generally required okay
the other lady diana conwarn she has abs
in mathematics from mit
and decided to go into science
communication
also she got a youtube channel
known as the physics girl and i think
recently she ended a
five-year re partnership with pbs she
decided to go all on her own because
she's
popular enough that she doesn't need pbs
or maybe pbs
fired her i don't know the details
anyways uh
why do these ladies do
irrationality why do they do religion
well today we're going to discuss how
they analyze
mr einstein and some of the
uh little things that happen in general
relativity some of the explanations we
get from
the establishment okay and by the way i
want to mention just uh
the fact that you know a person like uh
this lady
um becky let me put her up here again
uh she does uh the fact that she's got a
doctor's degree
a phd degree uh it's it's really
uh not important because it depends on
you know what uh what you studied here
we have a
famous fellow his name is um william
lane craig
and he wrote a book uh on the uh
uh what is it the cosmological
argument that he's got uh for the
existence of god with an emphasis on the
alleged metaphysical impossibility
of an infinite regress of past events
and his doctoral thesis
he's a doctor right ph.d the historical
argument
for the resurrection of jesus during the
deist
controversy how's that for a doctor's
degree
so yeah a lot of these people get
doctor's degree and i'm wondering really
how much they're worth and in fact
dr becky is no different she got a
degree in mathematics
whether that has any value at all i
don't know she did spend time but like
mr john baez says you know
uh in his uh crackpot index
nobody cares how long you spent
uh trying to figure out something you
know it's irrelevant
it's whether you have that moment in
which you see you know how the universe
works
otherwise you know he did was warm a
desk or a seat
you know at the uh in college okay
so um first thing that becky does in her
her
presentation i'm gonna go with her first
uh is pay homage to einstein
you absolutely must pay homage to
einstein if you're gonna do
if you're gonna do uh communication
science communication physics
communication
otherwise uh people will be turned off
you know because
you really have to respect the gods of
general relativity
okay and here uh put this over here
here she is uh she says the following
about uh
mr einstein to begin with her uh one of
the things that physicists
find ourselves saying all the time is
that einstein was right
now how's that for a starting point you
got to say that einstein was right you
can't say that einstein was wrong
because otherwise you got a big problem
with a lot of people okay his theory of
general relativity is the best
description we have for how gravity
works
well she already starts with a
contradiction okay
theory is an explanation she's talking
about the best description
so uh how how can we have a theory
that is a description and uh and confuse
that you know with uh
with uh the fact that let me get
something here right here
uh how can we have uh a description and
call that a theory you know if someone
asks you how something happened
you're not gonna say what happened one
plus one equals two
what do you mean one plus one equals two
is that your theory yeah
that's my theory no that's not a theory
a theory is an explanation of something
you gotta explain how something happened
especially in physics
and so we have a problem here because
she talks about theory of general
relativity
and she says the best description so
obviously she did not learn that in
science school wherever she studied i
guess she studied at that
oxford monastery or whatever so yeah
uh every test we put it through it
passes with flying colors
uh we don't test theories in science in
physics
uh you know because testing just means
you want to prove to yourself that
you're right
or you want to prove to someone else
that you're right and in science we
don't prove
and therefore we do not present evidence
to convince
persuade convert and recruit people they
do that in sunday school
maybe at oxford what christ church maybe
that's where they do it
but not in science we don't do that in
science so she says so
does that mean that we can just pat
ourselves on the back
because the job's done you know
you got to leave a little room for the
new generations because if einstein did
it all right and figured it all out
what's there for anybody else to do you
know we're done with physics
so they have to leave that door open and
say we don't know everything
oh we don't know every i thought we did
i mean i thought einstein was right and
proven right and
uh everything's peachy with with uh
einstein and here they say well he was
correct he was right
he was true right but uh he's not
quite there yet you know so that's
that's that little
bit that they have job security with
right
and says no we are still testing gravity
we're coming up with different theories
of gravity
so uh what is a theory let's find out
what a theory is because
apparently uh this lady is very confused
in what a theory is
okay let's find out what a theory is
theory it says incense this is not for
me by the way
in science and explanation
or model that covers a substantial group
of occurrences in nature
and i would put a period there but they
continue because these are mathematical
notions that i have been introduced into
science which have no business in
science
says has been confirmed by a substantial
number of experiments and observations
by whom by the vatican uh
by the dalai lama i mean who confirmed
this
i mean here we're talking about
confirmation confirmation
is an issue of belief not an issue
that concerns science in science we
explain a mechanism
we show it on the screen objectively and
once we understand it that's it you know
then you can uh
you you can believe in it or not if you
want if you want evidence you can go and
get evidence uh to run your own
experiment try to convince yourself or
convince
others that part is religion science
ends at explanation of an objective
mechanism that's it once you visualize
the mechanism once you see it
you're done that's the science part now
the rest
the rest is religion belief
uh opinion okay a theory is more general
is more general and better verified than
a hypothesis
absolutely not okay that's only in the
religion of mathematics
that they do that where they verify and
they say well this is more
we more people voted for this than for
that other one so that one's still not a
theory this one's a theory
and when everybody raises their hand we
call it proof
it's been verified to exhaustion
everybody believes in it
what believes until a new one comes
around and said well you were all wrong
you know
we were maybe we all believed in the
flat earth at some point in time in the
past but then slowly we got away from
that
what was truth then stop being truth
later on
which again it means all we did was
change opinions
it's not that the the flat earth was
proven
it was guaranteed it was that at the
time people
believed that it was flat and they had
all kinds of evidence and proof and
experiments to show that the earth was
flat
so uh no we don't do experiments we
don't present
evidence but this is what this uh lady
was taught and she just repeats it just
regurgitates it
you know uh like a poem okay and no
hypothesis
is not what it follows here i put that
in there because it says verified
more better verified than a hypothesis
hypothesis a proposition
or set of propositions set forth as an
explanation
now a hypothesis is not an explanation
for the occurrence of some specified
group of phenomena either asserted
merely as a provisional conjecture
to guide investigation working
hypothesis
or accept it as highly probable in the
light of established facts
none of that has anything to do with a
hypothesis in fact you'll find
many synonyms of hypothesis among them
assumption prediction
uh you know asking a question
there's all these synonyms for
hypothesis and people don't really know
what a hypothesis in b
is because it's got like 10 different
notions
of what a hypothesis is a hypothesis is
an assumption and what does it include
for rational science
includes the objects you're going to
introduce for physics
the ones you're going to put on the
screen includes the definitions
and of course it includes the initial
scene we need to know where you started
you know to do your your theory okay
and your theory had better follow from
the hypothesis
okay uh this lady continues she begins
with einstein's equation
she does a very quick analysis that
really
glosses over a lot of stuff but in a way
it's not so important
and i'll show you why she says what the
tensors do is mathematically describe
how space is curved
by an object with mass that's all she
says and essentially that's all that you
really need to know about this entire
equation which is einstein's equation
okay
uh the left-hand side of the equation of
the equal sign
okay it talks about the curvature of
space-time the one on the right talks
about mass and energy
and if we follow mr john wheeler he
tells us that
mass tells space time how to curve and
space times tells
mass how to move and that's essentially
what this equation does
do you see an explanation of anything in
there
no obviously you'll never find an
explanation in all of mathematical
physics
except the irrational ones right but i
mean rational explanations you won't
find them there because
all of their stuff is just math
equations
equations have nothing to do with
physics physics
is physics and math and math is math and
never the tween shall meet okay
so one thing is an equation that says
well
space is curved and mass tells space how
to curve and then
uh one space is curved which is you know
like a
circular argument once uh space is
curved it tells mass how to move
great and that's essentially what
einstein's equation is
all about okay so uh here we'll go with
a simpler equation for those of you who
are familiar with it
okay and this is uh look not me
pull this other guy out i mean get him
uh here's uh newton's equation and
what he said mass mass divided by
distance squared
and that gives you an idea why he said
the earth doesn't leave the solar system
okay but he says hypothesis nonfingel i
framed no hypothesis why he was a
particle man
you know particle man particle man
he was a particle man and he could not
explain
this magic trick with particles
okay and that's essentially what caused
his downfall at the turn of the 20th
century
when all these guys like lawrence and
einstein and
minkowski they came in there and they
said oh look we have a better
uh physical interpretation and that
physical interpretation was what
warped space warp space-time sorry
didn't mean to leave that time factor
out okay so he had no hypothesis he was
honest he said look i don't know how it
works but
all i can do is describe it
mathematically and if they would have
stopped there
right we have no problem with that you
know i have no problem with newton's
equation
and i don't have a problem with him
saying look uh we don't understand
gravity we don't know how it works
all we can do is uh describe it
mathematically
but einstein purported to do something
else he purport to
explain the mechanism okay and of course
after that they just say uh
oh by the way we don't understand it or
we can't visualize it which means the
same thing
you know they can't understand it
because they can't make a movie
of it and put it on the screen for you
they can do a two-dimensional movie and
they say well it's an
analogy you got to think of you know you
got to extrapolate flatland to
solid land solid land to the fourth
dimension
to the tesseract land or whatever right
you know four-dimensional world out
there that they claim exists
okay uh she continues and she tries to
explain a little more
about what these uh tensors are okay so
she goes into a little bit of that she
says with tensors we appreciate
the full four dimensions of space time
great there's three dimensions of space
of space i thought objects had
dimensions
well in relativity they made space into
an object and they think it's a thing
and so they talk about the
three-dimensional little space and that
comes all the way from
geometry all the way from the days of uh
the greeks
so they always called solids they call
it space
or 3d space or whatever no not in
science not in physics in physics
space is nothing that which has no shape
and an object that which is 3d in
general right
an object is that which has shape so
there we have it
we have space and and something nothing
in something there are antonyms we can
use them consistently in any
discussion what are the three dimensions
of space according to this lady what did
she
learn by memory and school what does she
regurgitate she says
the three dimensions of space forward
and back left and right
up and down i didn't know there was a
dimension called forward and back have
you ever heard of that
i i i don't know of a dimension known as
left and right
or up and down no no those are not
dimensions first of all those are known
as
vectors in physics because the vectors
represent
motion dimensions do not have
anything to do whatsoever with motion
she didn't learn these basic things in
in college or in high school i don't
know where she learned this stuff
uh no there are no such things as
no no dimensions as uh left and right
and front and back and
whatever nonsense that is okay
so let's see if we can educate her on
what a dimension
is and why mathematics does not have
dimensions coordinates or vectors they
don't use those things okay they have
something else okay
what they have are number lines which
they confuse
with dimensions coordinates and vectors
okay the dimensions of
physics are the one on the left there
and you see its
orientation length width and height
coordinates have to do with location
and not with structure or orientation
it has to do with the location of
something in in space you could say okay
and then vectors have to do with the
three possible motions an object can
move in three
mutually perpendicular dimensions from a
given location
math math is something totally different
math only has number lines and what they
do is they you call these vectors they
call them coordinates they call them
dimensions
when all they are is number lines
mathematicians don't care
about uh dimensions of qualitative
dimensions coordinates or vectors what
they care about is numbers
they care about magnitudes and those are
all number lines what a number line has
is a um
has magnitude but it has no direction
and people see that little arrow at the
end of the line and say oh there's
direction
no no no you can put the number line in
any direction you want because a number
line has
no direction number line just says that
numbers increase or decrease or whatever
number line has nothing to do with
physics
with the physical notions of dimensions
coordinates or vectors
okay so every time a mathematician
pronounces the word dimension
coordinate or vector he's going to talk
about a number line
okay and what they've done in order to
you know sneak it into physics they
gave magnitudes direction so now we have
a series of numbers that have direction
as well the direction part belongs to
physics
the numbers the number line that belongs
to math
and nevertheless shall meet because one
is qualitative the other one is
quantitative so that's how they got
messed up
with dimensions coordinates and vectors
that's how they mixed up
the mat the uh number lines with that
okay that's that's how they
got into they they get their foot into
physics with that okay
because now they're going to talk about
dimensions coordinates or vectors
when they have no business talking about
that in this in the context of number
lines
okay um
then she goes in there and says well you
know uh general relativity is
right it's correct you know because in
math fizz
what is important to them is whether
you're correct or not whether your
opinion is right
they don't care about objective
explanations that you can see
on the screen you know if i want to know
how the uh
box was pulled by a pulley well i make a
movie of it i said look this is how the
box went up
uh i pulled down on a rope through that
was
wound around the pulley and i tucked on
that and that's how the box went up
and you watch it you see and you say
okay i understand it
you know because we all eight billion
people on earth unless maybe you're
blind you know
watch that and say okay i understand
what happened the box went up because i
pulled on the rope that went through a
pulley
that's how physics works that's not how
these people work they talk about
did i prove it to you okay here's the
equation let me prove it to you through
an equation what's an equation of
description it's not a mechanism
okay they can't have a theory in
mathematics because mathematics does not
deal with explanations
and theories are explanations only
okay so this lady goes in there again
she has to
paint a little homage to uh good old
einstein
she says everywhere and every way we've
been able to test general relativity
it's predictions predictions astrology
okay predictions have been right they're
not wrong they can't be wrong because if
they're wrong we got a lot of people
unemployed up
up there you know the high place and no
no they have to always be right
and of course for that they had to
introduce censorship and
forbid people to attack the theory of
theory of general authority the
explanation the physical interpretation
of general relativity
on the basis of irrationality
they say well you know we we know it's
irrational but we don't care about that
because that's a physical interpretation
and we don't do that here in
mathematical physics that's on the other
side of campus they do that
over there in philosophy of science or
philosophy or physics or some
ontology course or whatever now here
what we do is equations
but then why did they try to give a
physical interpretation to it
because they want because otherwise
mathematics would be worthless garbage
we wouldn't care about math if it had
nothing to do
with physics so they had to incorporate
math into physics and create this thing
called math
mathematical physics which we call
mathematics
because all the explanations all 100
percent
of the explanations of mathematical
physics related to invisible mechanisms
invisible
agents invisible intangible agents like
gravity like
magnetism and so on they have no
explanation no rational explanation for
any of those okay so that's why you have
to invent you know principles like you
know
uh uncertainty and complementarity and
so on
or uh what's the other um the
equivalence of
einstein's equivalence which i discussed
in the past
okay so everything from planet orbits to
pulsars to black holes to gravitational
waves
it's all evidence evidence proof
i'm going to convince you i'm going to
persuade to recruit you
evidence in favor of einstein's theory
of general relativity
okay says
those equations that he came up with are
thought to
govern everything from the expansion of
the universe to the behavior of black
holes
to how gravitational waves move through
uh
space to the formation of every single
structure
in the universe from the smallest planet
to the biggest galaxy to the biggest
clusters of galaxies
okay so what is that gravitational waves
what the hell is that
uh how can they move through space if
here you have it
okay if uh gravitational
well a wave of any kind you know if
space
is the black stuff i don't know what the
particles are
but the particles they say are the space
they say that space is made of particles
okay and i don't know what gives shape
to each one of their particles if
if uh if the particles are space and
space as particles
so we have a little problem there but
then what is the way well the wave
is not a separate entity that moves
through space like she says there no it
can't be
if that wave came over here it's the
vibration
of the ether which is all those
particles which make up space which
is space itself so it's space itself
which is vibrating
because uh you know like when they found
these alleged
two black holes that collided uh and
then from there they came out they had
all these waves comes towards us
uh which they claimed to measure and
they got a nobel prize for that okay um
but what happened well the two
things allegedly collided what did they
vibrate
what was it that was waving all the way
to earth
was it the particles was it the uh space
itself
what was vibrating we need to identify
that thingy
and see they don't do that so she talks
about waves
going through space like a space or
something else
no it's the vibration of space itself
according to general relativity
so it's space which is vibrating so you
can't talk about
the wave vibe going through space you
you can talk about
space vibrating or you know oscillating
or whatever
so that has to be clarified of course
they can't make a movie of what they're
saying because they can't
because as soon as they put what i just
put up there let me put that one
more time there okay if they're gonna
put this thing here right well then you
have to identify what's
what you're staring at what are you
staring at are you staring at um
the ether are you staring at space are
you staring at particles are you staring
at a wave what is that
what do you mean the wave went through
space
so that's the issue they can't
illustrate this and of course
none of mathematical physics can be
illustrated
which means it's irrational because a
theory of physics a mechanism of physics
has to be illustratable if you can't
illustrate it
it doesn't belong to physics period
we're done
okay it's just that's how simple it is
physics is only about explaining
mechanisms
and the rest is all mere opinion as mr
uh
democritus would say okay okay
um this lady continues but what about
the areas where we've
not been able to test general relativity
okay
yeah for example around bigger and more
energetic objects and then she talks
about the smallest one she says the
entire universe perhaps
or on the opposite scale the tiniest
objects in the universe such as
particles the quantum level and there
you have uh
their famous planetary atom which is the
one they still use to do
what electricity uh quantum jumping
ionization they do it all with this
monster
okay and of course they cannot explain
what holds the bead
to the nucleus why doesn't the bead
the blue electron bead there why doesn't
spontaneously fly away that's what they
cannot explain what holds it to the
proton or to the nucleus to begin with
and of course then they have those
little um
gluons there that uh hold the quarks
together and
the red stuff you can think of as a sea
of uh
gluons and the question is uh
how do particles hold the quarks
together i mean the gluons are supposed
to be particles discrete particles
we don't know what surrounds them
because you have to give shape to each
gluon but
that's one issue the other issue is that
okay i'll give you all the particles you
got you got the whole sandbox
show me how in a sandbox you know the
balloon attracts the
basketball on the other side of the
sandbox
show me the mechanism how do how do you
do it with particles
okay and yeah what they do is they say
well we're going to try to introduce
general relativity into the particle
world and that's
known today as string theory it's a
string theory is trying to
merge quantum mechanics with general
relativity what they say is quantization
of space time you know look at the
little points
in fact uh nothing's really changed
because space time has always said that
space time itself is made of points it's
made of
events what's an event a point in space
time it's a
you know circular argument right
what constructs space time is a bunch of
events in each event is a point in space
time
and what is a point in space and what's
uh one that you locate with four
coordinates or uh really four number
lines
right and uh you locate it with four
number lines
and that's gives you four coordinates
and that gives you
the unimaginable uh space type that
they're talking about
always unimaginable everything in
mathematical physics is
unimaginable they've given up on that
like mr feynman said
okay and so she continues if general
relativity is correct
correct it's got to be correct can't or
right right can't be uh
false ever cannot be allowed to fail too
big to fail
then it predicts another prediction and
we're gonna
[Music]
crystal ball we're gonna do some
predictions here that 96
of the universe is dark and doesn't
interact with light
okay it's dark yeah i know i look at the
sky i see that it's all dark
and uh in between the darkness you see
some little lights
uh is it 96 well maybe yeah i don't know
i haven't counted the percentages but
yeah there's more darkness out there
than there is light
so what okay so what's the point here
and it says
it predicts another prediction okay that
dark energy
oh energy energy is the same energy that
mr feynman says
you know us mathematicians we have no
idea what energy is
said in the final lectures okay
so he said they don't know what energy
is but it's all made of energy
out there 70 of the universe and we
don't know what it is
of course you don't know what it is
because energy is not a what
you know you can say um the universe is
made of
i don't know rocks or horses that
wouldn't make sense
because more sense than this at least
because you can imagine a bunch of
horses you know making the whole
universe okay fine
but when you say it's made out of energy
it's like saying it's made out of love
what do you mean it's made out of love
what sense does that make
and then she said well we don't know
what love is which yeah i know
because it's not a what love is a
concept it's a dynamic concept and so is
energy
so you can't talk about energy because
energy is a mathematical concept that
they
introduce in an equation and they can't
put a horse in any equation they can't
put a rock in an equation or a tree
they have to put the mass of the horse
or the length of the tree or some
number in there and that's what they do
with energy because energy is not a what
energy is a concept
she never learned this in however many
years she studied to get her phd
it is this mysterious force or energy
yeah it's got to be mysterious okay
because you can't imagine it that's
acting against gravity to cause this
expansion of the universe to speed up
well yeah universe is a concept so the
universe
concepts don't expand okay so uh
to say that uh universe expands is like
saying
intelligence expands what what sense
does that mean okay
and universe is a concept there's no
physical object standalone
object called the universe okay
you can talk about the matter in the
universe that's
one component the other component is
known as space and space is nothing so
we have a concept we have a relationship
between an object and a concept which we
treat momentarily as an object
what is a concept a word that includes
two objects or words
treated as objects in this case space
universe
treats spaces if it were a physical
object they say
here we have matter and here we have
space it's a concept so you can't say
the universe expands you got to say
either
space expands if you're going to treat
space as an object or you're going to
say
matter in the universe is exploding
okay there's this explosion all the
matter is
separating we have a hand grenade here
all the debris is spreading out
so these are two different notions but
they just say oh the universe is
expanding they fixed it with that
okay okay then the other chunk of the
universe is dark matter
dark matter it's always dark racism
that's what i call it racism
and there's so much evidence evidence
for dark matter it's all just
gravitational
in nature that is we don't see it
okay we have evidence but we don't see
it
it's like the ear you know i have
evidence of air because i i move my hand
at least i can touch it here you can't
see it or touch it
okay keep that in mind okay
we don't see it with our eyes
necessarily but we see its influence
due to gravity they see these things
indirectly they say this is what we do
see
and we call what caused it
dark matter or dark energy or dark
people i don't know whatever
they invent these concepts and they said
that's what's moving it
well no the way it works in science and
physics you've got to identify that
object you've got to show me a picture
of
it first then you can tell me that
this is what moves that one it's not an
issue of evidence it's an issue of
please draw it so that we can see the
mechanism
what the hell are you talking about what
is this dark matter
she says we don't know what it is she's
got to tell me what it is
especially if she's going to say that
there's a lot of evidence for its
existence
then she's got to put it on the board
this is like saying you know
god is what moves everything okay can
you draw god
oh i don't know what he looks like
because you know i've never seen him
i've never had contact with god
oh no draw god and then i can then you
can show me with his hands how he pushes
things around then i can understand the
mechanism
but if you say well god is this concept
this
this unimaginable being all you're doing
is putting it beyond reason
and that's what these people do with all
this okay they're talking about the
influence the
the indirect impact that whatever is out
there
has on the visible things and they infer
they surmise that there's something out
there they call that dark matter
but see when we come to the conference
and give the presentation the
dissertation
you got to stand up there with a
microphone say uh okay let me tell you
now
what dark matter is what i propose it is
it's this and you point to it and people
are going to see something on the screen
and say oh i see what dark energy is or
dark matter or whatever
dark whatever it's all dark now you can
see the mechanism you see okay i see
that this is pushing that so i can see
how the universe is
expanding or whatever but until you
identify the physical object
what the hell are you talking about
this is the problem these people do not
identify it because they don't know what
they're talking about
okay uh so what is this dark uh thingy
that they found well this
this is just a quick uh version the bill
gate
version uh i don't call it dark matter i
call it dark kilograms
okay dark kilograms why because they're
light there because all the kilograms i
had to put them
as a contrast again uh the black space
in the in the background
game yeah what they found out is that
galaxies don't rotate like the solar
system
solar system you know pluto takes a long
time to go around the
the sun 248 years earth years whereas uh
what is it
um mercury takes what 88 days
so this guy goes real fast around the
sun mercury and pluto takes a long time
to go around
that's not what happens here here the
stars on the outer side of a galaxy
move faster or at least as fast as the
ones on the inside
and that violates newton and violates
einstein
and another guy named mond who i'll talk
about in a second here
you know violates everybody's equation
so they have to cheat and they say well
the only thing that could be causing it
is gravity that's the only thing they
could think of
gravity and if it's gravity okay
fine uh what they had to do is sprinkle
kilograms on the outside of the galaxy
and they said
with this ad hoc invention
right we can explain how a
galaxy sticks together and more or less
turns like you know
a carousel all at the same time more or
less
some stars on the outside go faster fine
but i mean
the the galaxy rotates you know as if it
were a single disc as if it were all
interconnected like in the rope model
the rope mono
all atoms are interconnected all stars
are physically
interconnected that's why a galaxy
rotates as a single disk
there's got to be a physical connection
between stars between
atoms in order for this to happen
instead of that they say no it's got to
be some
it's got it's got to be some
[Music]
some masses on the outside okay it's got
to be some mess that's on the outside
and that's holding it all together i
just got a
call on uh from my wife
so i better behave now okay the wife's
on uh
watching probably
let me write to her real quick
okay
okay let me continue here
um okay next topic
this lady continues and um
she says the following she says so all
those things dark energy dark matter
really do raise the question
of whether general relativity that has
served us so well
so far on all scales we've been able to
test it on
is maybe not the full picture because
there are things that they claim that
maybe general relativity maybe
einstein's equation does not
answer completely okay especially at the
atomic level and maybe at the grand
level beyond
what we can see in other words at the
universal level
the big and the small the extremes okay
it's not that einstein was wrong
you have to always uh
pay homage to einstein einstein was not
wrong
you can't say that einstein was wrong
okay
because otherwise you know they're going
to execute you
[Laughter]
just like newton wasn't wrong newton
wasn't wrong either none of them were
wrong
none of them ever can be wrong because a
lot of people would lose their jobs if
these guys were wrong
okay it's just that in the scales that
we're looking at it just
maybe needs modifying slightly okay
so now what uh the new generations will
be working out for the next
uh gazillion years will be on modifying
what little einstein left for them
just the modifications just tweaking
that equation back and forth until
you know kingdom come that's what they
do now that's how they
make their books okay she does propose
says well
there's a lot of alternative theories
that uh people are working on a lot of
well i don't want to call them
alternative because alternative theories
are used to um
what is it uh do you mean to uh
uh laugh at uh people like the electric
universe which
i i agree with them you know i would
laugh at the electric universe as well
or uh the etherist of uh john chapel
society
and uh ken wheeler and all these other
guys who come up with all these
uh weird um theories
and so they laugh at them and they call
those alternative theories so
these are not really alternative
theories they're like branches
from um from the mainstream okay
but mains but branches which bother the
mainstream
but they say see we have all these
theories that are challenging us but
we've always been able to reject them
because they have no place
under what we under mainstream but it
was good that they came to challenge us
okay
so that's that's the idea they want to
say that there's a scientific debate
no there isn't no scientific debate
because it's pure censorship
okay and one of them is mond m-o-n-d
okay modified newtonian dynamics
and another one is uh the possibility
right
at a new gravitational field to general
relativity like a fifth force
okay they have these four horses of the
apocalypse
in uh general in mathematical physics in
general they have uh
the electromagnetic for horse the
gravitational horse they have the uh
gluon for
a horse and they have the weak horse
they're all where the four horses that i
call them of the apocalypse
and they say there could be a fifth
horse okay that's when it
hopefully wins the race okay and so they
could modify the equation by putting
this little new force that could be out
there you know it's just a modification
of einstein's equation
and another one is to add extra
dimensions which is what strength theory
essentially does okay
okay but she begins to reject some of
these
uh she says this one for example monde
okay
proposed by this fellow more than high
hip milgram and i'm just going to go
real
quickly over it you see those a's there
it's newton's equation
and it's multiplied by this factor it's
got the a on top a on the bottom but
this guy proposes that there's a
different
acceleration for things that could
replace
the uh dark matter out there and that
could cause the same effect
okay that's what he proposed um
and what happened to him well he had no
no
um
no success okay he had no success
um and this was why
okay or this is what she says at least
says that mon predicts
that gravitational waves should travel
at different speeds than the speed of
light
but in 2017 we detected the exact same
object at the exact same time a burst of
light
and gravitational waves suggesting that
they travel at the same speed
and that was a huge blow for that theory
so that was the end of le mans
okay that was the end of him okay or at
least apparently this is what the
establishment considers that uh mund is
dead
and i guess i'm sure there's a lot of
people still doing
mund out there and who believe in that
stuff okay here's the
other one the string theory and her
opinion
on this is gravity is governed by the
exchange of particles
actually it's a string called the
graviton okay that's under
string theory okay to work string theory
needs ten dimensions
but not the four of space and time that
we're familiar with
well i don't know if she's familiar with
it i only recognize three dimensions
length width and height i don't know any
other dimension other than that
time is a number line not a dimension
and
uh in fact that's all that mathematical
physics has
uh number lines and then she says the
issue with string theory is that it
doesn't give you
any explanation for dark energy it can
reduce any
it can't reduce any sort of repulsive
force that could explain the accelerated
expansion
in the universe okay uh well
i would reject it on a different basis
and that's that if
uh string theory says that all these
particles
are just vibrations of strings
one-dimensional strings another nonsense
that doesn't exist out there you know
but
these people say there's one dimensional
strings they vibrate and they create
these particles
okay fine that's their
their argument fine now you got the
particle now explain how the particles
pull how the particles cause attraction
okay that's all you got to explain just
explain the mechanism
in fact don't explain it keep your mouth
shut just make a
movie of it so that i can watch it i can
see the mechanism with my
own eyes then i'll understand it for
sure okay so you all you got to do is
explain
you know how uh particles produce
uh accelerated or acceleration
gravitational acceleration
in the direction of another object
that's what you got to explain
very simple okay so once they explain
the mechanism we'll all understand it
and again
all they have to do is make the movie
you can't make a movie of it you don't
have a
theory of physics you have a theory of
mathematics
okay and how does he end well if she
rejects all these other
competitors within mathematical physics
she says
so our best theory for how the universe
works is still one where general
relativity is the best description
theory is a description we have for
gravity and of course einstein
sticks his tongue at all of us
[Laughter]
but if you accept einstein's theory of
general relativity then you have to
accept that dark matter and dark energy
are things so now we have these concepts
somehow they morphed into things
okay okay that's uh
good old becky okay let's go with uh
other lady now what did she talk about
what she talks about just about
everything she did
uh becky didn't talk about which is
black holes
okay so here we have uh our dear friend
diana
okay and she says she also starts with
einstein's equation
and she says according to einstein's
field equation the gravity of an object
is proportional to its density
there you have it in the equation so if
an object is dense
enough then nothing that gets too close
can never escape no matter what
nothing not even light can escape from
an ultra dense object
we call that object a black hole
no absolutely not okay
that's not a black hole is okay
and it's not an object that's dense
enough that's not the real
definition let's find out what the
definition of this is okay
so that uh diana here uh learns it as
well
okay here we have mr stephen hawking i
mean how much more
authority do you want than that i mean
you're going to believe on authority
here you have it
and this is what he says in his book he
says chandrasekhar calculated that
he was a nobel prize by the way
chandrasekhar indian fella
okay calculated that a cold star of more
than
about one and a half times the mass of
the sun would not be able to support
itself against its own gravity
would it collapse to infinite density
this is only in this book okay
eddington was shocked by that
implication and he refused to believe
chandrasekhar's result
eddington thought it was simply not
possible that a star could collapse to a
point
einstein himself wrote a paper in which
he claimed that stars would not shrink
to zero size okay that was the issue
and he continues he says however he was
awarded the nobel prize in 1983 for his
early work on the limiting mass of cold
stars
chandrasekhar had shown that the
exclusion principle could not
halt the collapse of a star more massive
than the chandra sucker
limit so um
that's uh about as much the authority as
you can get right i mean
you're gonna all these people believe on
earth in authority there you have it
okay
more authority than stephen hawking okay
and uh so here's uh
another couple evidence proof so that we
can convince you do a little religion
here okay persuade you
recruit you zero them in so leonard
showed
and he wrote a paper this guy leonard
showed that black hole radius
is zero i mean how much
uh how much more proof do you want than
that he showed in his paper and when he
was published right that a black hole's
radius is
zero okay scientists now refer to an
object with zero volume
but all of its mass as a singularity
that's what a black hole is so this uh
event horizon that forms
allegedly the region of influence of
what
of a singularity which is infinite
density because it has no volume
whatsoever there is no
size and so a lot of people don't
understand that they
especially i'm sure these girls would
not understand that either
they think that it's just uh very dense
that's all they think about they say
well it's it's very small
it's infinitesimal small but it's still
small
no it's zero size zero
volume that's what a black hole is why
would it stop there
why would it stop at any radius
whatsoever
and then see it never comes to their
mind they say i mean if i have a star
that's
humongously big and let's make it even
worse let's assume that
star turns into a black hole let's
concede that
and now the black hole begins to swallow
other stars massive stars just
sucks them in well with all that mass
going in they're being crushed out of
existence because
that's what black hole does crutches
matter out of existence
it just turns structure into mass in
other words the ghost of mass remains
but the structure
goes to heaven or the hell i don't know
and so you have more and more mass
at some point the mass is so great that
there can't be any structure in there so
there is no structure there is no size
there is no radius there is no diameter
did i miss one there is no nothing
that's what a black hole is a nothing
that's only got mass a mathematical
concept
it's like there's no elephant but the
five tons
are still there so you know he walks
into the china shop and
hits everything you don't see anything
but there's nothing there but it's the
mass that's
doing it that's what these people are
saying they're dealing with ghosts with
spirits
but they don't realize that they've been
so brainwashed they don't even know what
they're saying anymore
okay and uh that's why i like to point
this out
okay here's the mass circularity what is
mass
okay well if you ask anybody on the
street
anybody who took high school they'll say
mass is the quantity of matter
okay and black hole crushes all matter
out of existence
so what is a black hole made of they say
it's made of mass
so we have a circular argument you know
we have a
black hole is made out of mass what is
mass quantity of matter or a measure of
quantity of matter
okay that means it's got some matter in
there no matter the black hole crushes
all matter out of existence that's what
these people are saying
okay so uh the first thing you have to
absolutely
fight is the issue of how
big uh black hole is does it have size
at all and the answer is no
and that's where the fight is because
once you have won that fight then a
black hole is irrelevant
totally irrelevant there is no such
thing as a black hole because
assuming we conceded it just disappeared
out of out of
uh the universe the concept universe
it became space became nothing and
the only thing they say well it's the
mass is still there why would it be
there if you crushed all matter out of
existence
and matters the quant and mass is the
quantity of matter
that's the idiotic reasoning of a
mathematical physicist
uh mathematician i'm sorry and uh
that's not where the nonsense of the
black hole stop start splitting
stops okay uh here's here you have a
little turtle he's going around
okay he's going around nothing and you
say well hold it
what's what's making him go around and
they say well mass
well how does mass do it i mean
and so they say well mass bends
space-time and then the
turtle just slides along space-time
that's your argument
okay but so so the issue is that
the turtle is going around only because
mass weighed down space-time but mass is
a concept
okay so this is the issue the issue is
that these people are playing with
ghosts and spirits that's how they're
doing their so-called physics their
physical interpretations which is the
only thing that
concerns physics the rest is math we
don't care about that they can put
anything they want in their equations if
they're going to cross the line into
physics we want a physical
mechanism okay
okay um here's uh
what these people say well you're not
supposed to take the an
analogy literally of you know mass
bending this
fishnet the fishnet you know that i just
showed
uh the turtle going around that fishnet
if i can put it back here the fishnet
you'll see in a second that fishnet
you're not supposed to take it literally
it's not real it's not
you know they just use it as an analogy
well if we remove the uh
the fishnet then what is the turtle
going around
so we have to put the fishnet if we're
going to give a physical
interpretation to it but then they say
they have these cartoons like this one
here
understanding gravity space time is like
a rubber sheet
massive objects distort the sheet and
what
student right they distort it because
they're
pulled down by what good question
and the professor says oh my god space
time is like this set of equations for
which
any analogy must be an approximation
what does an approximation have to do
with an objective
mechanism what they have to explain is
the mechanism
and they explain it with a rubber sheet
with the fish in it with the trampoline
with a canvas and then they say oh but
don't take it literally because the
canvas is
not really there we just put it in there
so that you could understand the
mechanism
[Laughter]
so they would throw the the canvas the
fishnet they they take it out and say
you're not supposed to take it literally
well i just need to explain this let me
show you what
what we need what these people need to
explain this is the tag this is the
million dollar question they have to
answer
okay this is what we're interested in
okay here we have the earth
and the earth goes around the sun okay i
hope you can see it all there
and uh they say there's a wall of warp
time
because they're gonna warp time they're
gonna treat time as a physical object
okay that's that's what they do that's
what general relativity is about warp
time gravity warps time
uh space time is warped time is part of
space time time is warped
so we have the earth going around the
sun and they're saying the sun
weighs down the canvas the
fishnet whatever of space-time fine
we can understand the mechanism because
there's a wall right it's like a
roulette
right the little ball doesn't fly out
why because there's a wall
preventing the little ball going around
from flying out
that's how simple it is right you unders
everybody understands the roulette you
just look at it and say okay i
understand the mechanism
but now they're going to remove the
roulette and they're going to leave the
little ball going around without a
roulette
and even worse they're going to say well
the wall is made out of warped time
that's part of the wall
and that's what prevents the earth from
flying out of the solar system
and so you say hold on you're saying
that this concept
called time is warped and that's the
physical entity that comes up against
the skin of the earth when the earth
rolls around the sun
it's orbit it's revolution that's why
the earth doesn't fly out
of the solar system because there's a
wall of warp time
and our answer is don't take the analogy
so literally
[Laughter]
so uh well you judged on your on your
own there
this is what these people say okay i was
going to go into
some of the things that this lady said
about geodesics i'm going to have to
leave that maybe for next time
let me just skip over that you might say
bill why are you beating up on these
poor ladies i mean they're fine ladies
beautiful
girls there you know certainly wouldn't
mind having them as my um
uh daughter-in-law's i i think
any parent would be proud of them for
sure but that's irrelevant in the
context
we're talking about what are we talking
about we're talking about you know these
people going out there and talking about
nonsense they're just repeating what
they memorized in school
you know they passed the test because
that's what the teacher told them was
the answer
they just memorized it you know mark the
scantron sheet letter d
you know they passed 100 points great
and now they just regurgitate they just
say whatever
they just parrot whatever they were
taught by wrote
the poem that they learned by heart
and that's what they now regurgitate
drew you to okay
now i've got my uh my uh
uh what is it uh
my countryman my countryman pope frankie
you know pope frankie he uh he said
who am i to judge
[Laughter]
that's what he said a lot of
conservatives didn't like uh that
statement you know he said it about gays
said who am i to judge
and by the way good old pope uh he he
was born near where i was born
this is the city of buenos aires and he
was born in a place called flores there
you can see that
area there the barrio uh close to
another fella which i'm gonna be talking
about his name is juan maldasena he's a
string theorist okay
uh me i was born on the other side of
the river you see that river there
riyacuelo that's what it's called
i was born where maradona was born uh in
a place called
la nus west la nous la nusso estimates
stands for west and the only or
one of the things i have in common with
the pope is that we're both uh fans of
san lorenzo which stands for
saint lawrence you say bill you traitor
you you're a fan of a team that worships
a saint
now his father lorenzo father uh
lawrence who uh was a good man he uh got
all the boys in the
region and he made a team out of them
and eventually became
one of the five most important teams in
argentina
anyways the the uh the pope says
uh you know who am i to judge but
i think it's a little too little too
late
i mean ask giordano bruno he was put
burned at the stake in 1600 before
saying that the universe was in
among other things universe was infinite
and that there were other worlds
probably populated and that was a big
problem because that means that maybe
jesus was not the
only begotten son of god
so they uh they blocked them as we would
say
they blocked uh good old giordano
they uh censored him you know they said
uh you know now we're not gonna let you
talk anymore we're gonna
light a match they burn them alive
okay okay uh so yeah what's the problem
with
uh these girls i wouldn't cry for them
you know don't cry for me argentina i
wouldn't cry for these
girls so much because they're laughing
all the way to the bank that's one issue
and uh the first girl becky um
she's got a little group of people that
help her out you know it's not like
she's alone she's also
helped by oxford and so on they don't
have a problem with her
going out there spreading the gospel of
general relativity
and here you have this the lady diana
and she's also you know she says
these are things that she said in an
interview she said my production budget
comes from pbs
now she i guess she's no longer with pbs
i think since september
she decided to hit it out on her own
because she's doing fine with
what she's doing she doesn't need pbs or
pbs doesn't need her i don't really know
okay
if it were if it were just the youtube
money i would be fine
so she's laughing all the way to the
bank okay so don't
feel so sorry for them i have five
people working with me a writer an
intern
i'm a fat checker fact checker okay
they ask her is there a downside to this
job she has creepy people online
like bill gatey i hope she was not
referring to people like me but she said
personal attacks and negative feedback
happened to any woman on the internet
well uh you know it's not about women
it's not about female it's not about you
being a girl
no or lady yeah no it's about
the nonsense that she's spreading that's
what it's about at least from my point
of view
okay so uh if i'm a creep uh well so be
it
i'll be a creep because what she's
spreading is nonsense okay
and uh so so again that's why i attack
them i think they're fair game
i i don't cry for these girls because
first they're doing fine and
i compliment them for that no problem i
have no problem with that at all
i'm just worried about what they're
spreading and they're the new generation
in fact these two girls have the
age of my youngest son hans you know so
uh
they're spreading this to the new
generations general relativity one more
generation that's gonna
hear about einstein how he was the
greatest you know celebrity ever
and how he had all this authority so
this is the problem
so now don't feel so bad about them okay
what these girls are are this
uh they are wolves in sheep's
clothing okay uh
they have their pretty faces online and
a lot of people just watch them or stay
tuned to them
why because they understand what you
they're talking about they know all the
things that are behind all these
statements that they make
no they go there but they say well i'm
gonna get my uh
what is it my dose of science this week
i'm gonna watch diana or i'm gonna watch
becky
so they go in they tune in they watch
these girls do they understand anything
about what they're talking about
of course not because they don't
understand it so how can the other guys
understand it
you know they don't have a physical
interpretation so what are they
understanding about gravity whether
especially gravity right but light
magnetism electricity
they don't understand any of the
mechanisms all they
do is just regurgitate what the
equations say and what they tell people
they can't talk about equations because
people would be tuned out immediately
no they have to tell them look this is
the physical interpretation and
all the physical interpretations are
irrational oh one's worse than the other
one
okay and so they say well it is so i
mean they could be telling them
angels they could tell in the public
about spirits
it wouldn't matter anyway they said well
i'd say prove that there are angels
einstein said that it's angels that
carry the earth around the sun
they would believe it as well they would
have no problem with that
okay because it comes from einstein
you're going to
question einstein so in a way
i'm ashamed of myself okay because i
treated these girls as nuns
twisted sisters right friendy
uh maybe maybe i'm wrong maybe
maybe maybe there's something else maybe
they're more like
this
they're cheerleaders for any is that
what it is is that what it's all about
just
entertainment you know and so
yeah i do have a problem with them i
think they're fair game when i attack
them
and i don't attack them for her for them
making money doing a business that's
fine i
love them for that but not the nonsense
that they're spreading that's where i
have a problem with them